kyle gibson the starter tonight for the
texas rangers this will be his 14th
start it has been an all-star caliber
season for the right-hander 3-1 pitch
this one back up the middle and right
there for it andy banyas and he'll go to
the bag to retire olson the inning is
done frankie montas making his 15th turn
of the season
just his fifth on the road though it's a
place where he's throwing the ball well
three and one 3.13 era on the road
second spot of the order tonight 226
average
will hempful smashed
and just into left field holt is on so
hold on with one out no score for
adolesce garcia
1-1 and that ball's blasted deep to
center field l'oreal on a dead sprint
back to the wall it's over his head
that one carries back toward the right
fielder canna around third base is holt
hill scores the balls cut off and the
rangers get that first run of the night
the double by adolesce garcia has the
rangers in front
one nothing a couple of men out there
for nate lowe this one lined past third
and that's a base hit garcia's in gallow
got a good start and they will throw up
the late stop sign he's got to hustle
back
and he just does get in there low with
an rbi double rangers lead to nothing
andy ibanez just up today and he's been
swinging a hot bat and he hammers that
ball deep out to left it is gone
[Applause]
a three run shut
and the rangers open it up
in the first inning the first big league
hit
in the first home run for andy abagnes
welcome back to the big leagues andy
avanyas a 1-0 breaking ball and you're
thinking i could probably get a strike
against a rookie who's not going to
offer at this pitch but ibanez was ready
look how quick the hands are short to
the ball he knew it as soon as he got it
and this is the kind of first inning
that the rangers have kind of been
waiting on
[Applause]
bounces one up the third baseline it's a
fair ball tough play for pinder and how
about the footwork by matt olson that
was awesome but the rangers bat around
and put five runs on the board heading
seven the shortstop number 17
elvis andrews
a long time face of the franchise and uh
associated with a lot of the franchises
great memories
came up in
2009 he's on those two world series
teams 1-1 pitch
little tapper right back to the mound
makes it easy on kyle gibson in fact
it's a quick one two three matt olson
leads it off for oakland here in the top
and that one on the ground diving stop
holt from anita first in time
and they get olson
a great mad scramble by the rangers
third baseman playing second that was a
tremendous play by brock holt
it was a back door breaking ball which
surprised me a little bit that that was
the pitch selection that they went with
but again it was perfectly located you
see the extension there from brock holt
but then to find the baseball right away
that's always the trick you knock it
down but where is it watch brock hold
right here finding the ball right in
front of him and making a very nice
throw from his knees
that's great work
look at that
so here's jed lowry now there strike
three called right on the inside corner
lowry didn't like it a strikeout for
kyle gibson his first of the night here
we go to the fifth it's five nothing
texas sean murphy grounded a second his
first time up
another hard hit ball the left this
one's going to sail over white's head
and it's out of the ball park
a line shot just over the wall first hit
for the ace and it's a home run a couple
of hard hit balls to open up the fifth
inning that one leaves the yard
we see murph go down and scoop this up
little change-up thing just kind of
stays true never starts to work its way
back so five to one the rangers lead
it's the sixth inning
line drive left center field garcia's
not to get this one
picks it up off the wall gets it back in
quickly and olson's got a lead off
double so here's ramon lauriano
my drive fair
into the corner olson's going to score
easily lorianno's gonna have an rbi
double and now it's five to two
well said these are starting to string
together line drive back-to-back dub
sacks for the green and gold
and he goes after the first pitch pops
it up left side of the infield and that
will end the inning connor falefa was
there the a's leave him loaded in the
sixth two on a two outs five for two
ranger lead couple of base runners or
jose trevino
and he hits this ball
deep to center field laureato on the run
what's up it's gone
a three run shot by trevino
and those are some huge insurance runs
for the rangers
that's a bomb to dead center field for
the ranger catcher remember earlier the
couple of foul tips that he took off his
body we wondered if he was going to stay
in the game you don't get jose trevino
out of the game he's built for big
moments like this 96 miles an hour
middle in and he put a charge into it
the second three-run home run for the
rangers tonight from a couple of their
young players only another solid night
he is one for two of the walk
tony camp a line shot and that's going
to be a base hit
kenner for
almost had it
kenny hits it hard in the left field and
that's a base hit so an opportunity to
get back in the game if you're the a's
runner goes and kemp's going to be safe
the ball is going to go into left field
and he's going to come in to score
so a little double steal by the a's they
get their third run
one two
and there's a swing in a missed strike
three lowry strikes out to leave two men
in scoring position
hayes have left five minutes on in the
last two innings alone so ninth inning
and veteran ian kennedy comes in has
been the rangers closer and he's really
done a nice job last year with oakland
camp at 247 but he's a guy he walked
more than he struck out last season and
he looks this one out into center field
and that's going to be a tough play
garcia makes a shoestring grab on the
run
and that is the first down of the inning
that's a really nice play from adobe's
garcia we were talking earlier about his
outs above average and
he is fourth in major league baseball
among outfielders you get caught in
between here do you want to slide or
dive for this one and
garcia decides to do neither and he's
got a better chance of catching it on
the run that's not easy to do catching a
baseball on the run near your feet
coming forward like that
we'll chop her over the mouth
oh bobble near second but holt recovers
again and he throws out olson and the
ball game is over
a one two three ninth inning for ian
kennedy
and he slams the door shut on an 8-3
rangers win